in our series a more perfect union we
aim to show that what unites us as
Americans is far greater than what
divides us this morning we're getting a
behind-the-scenes look at a unique high
school performing arts program that
brings different cultures and
generations together students in East
Los Angeles are learning historic
Mexican folk dances some of them
hundreds of years old their parents and
grandparents loved these traditions
growing up but they left them behind
when they came to America
Jamie yuccas shows us how a new
generation is inspiring the community
with a few carefully choreographed steps
[Music]
this may look like a professional dance
company
but these are actually high school
students from esperanza college prep in
primarily Hispanic East Los Angeles here
we go
ignacio delgado hernandez was a
professional dancer before he started
teaching okay parts he wanted to teach
what he knew best the traditional style
of mexican cultural dance known as
folkloric Oh
[Music]
Mexican folk dance for me provided a
space when I was growing up where I
could one find myself meaning that I was
also undocumented I could never go back
to Mexico and so it allowed me to
reconnect with my own identity growing
up feel pride in it to hoping as
students would feel that same pride he
asked to put on a year in production
with one condition according to
principal Rosa Elena
Alana's he told me every student's going
to dance and I said no way how are you
gonna make 14 year-olds who don't even
like this music dance he's like they
will dance Nicolas Mirana was a
typically skeptical freshman when he
first put on dance shoes the first few
days were like what is this like it's so
it was just weird you didn't think it
was cool nope slowly but surely as they
are developing their discipline and
their skill they fall in love with it an
even deeper bond form when mirana
brought the folkloric OU program home to
his father Hernan who grew up in Mexico
I danced for about three or four years
when I was 10 years old I don't remember
once the last time I saw for coracle
group dance it's like being back at home
seeing myself on him dancing onstage at
the end of the day that's my reward i
watch you perform on stage coming for
him it's me
[Music]
parents and grandparents from across the
community felt the same way hundreds
volunteered to do everything from hand
sewing hundreds of costumes to creating
dozens of elaborate hairstyles I'm gonna
start braiding your hair okay
Lorena averey's late mother used to
perform back in Mexico now her daughter
Daniela is dedicating her performance to
her grandmother well I actually do look
like Mike I'm like it's really
surprising when I saw it like I started
teeing up I was like wow I cannot
believe this and like she's like an
angel watching over me grandparents get
emotional because they're like this is
something that I grew up doing that I
had to stop doing because I crossed a
border all cultures have something to
offer right in something beautiful that
needs to be shown that needs to be seen
by the masses now the masses are seeing
it we got this okay at the end of its
first year the folkloric ou program
filled a 600 C theater this past summer
it sold out a playhouse holding 1,300
people
[Music]
once we got on stage and we do this show
they really see the reward they feel the
reward they feel a celebration which I
think any kid wants to feel celebrated a
[Music]
celebration bridging cultures and
crossing generations for CBS this
morning
Jamie yuccas Los Angeles fabulous
costume Lucas I like the line all
cultures have something to offer yes I
think that all those costumes were made
by relatives you can feel the love in
the room and on the stage I like the
guys saying I didn't think it was cool
and now look at him and those kids are
great yeah and the father seeing a son
on stage that's my reward see love that
piece Jaime he's very nice